documentary about the mortal notes about
the time the call fragrant Dan and the
modal nodes the cantina band is beyond
unfair these guys made their mark not
just on Tatooine but across the entire
galaxy the type of music they played was
known as jeers which caused some
confusion well I'm actually on the
original demo of the cantina song some
people are like these guys only had one
song but that's alive and they had like
17 albums I produced nine of them I was
a cantina regular they were a very tight
band a very tight and why are you
smiling like that it's a disease I can't
stop we were so good people almost
didn't care that we had heads that look
like butt cracks
they look like testicles with eyes but
they sounded like heaven it was the 70s
she could play a clue Leonora or a fond
father you were dropping pennies left
and right that was the times I don't
even know why I'm yelling but he was too
tired my first contract was actually
with Jabba the Hutt working for Jabba
get one wrong note boom you're in a
rancor pit hit another wrong note boom
you're in a Sarlacc pit the guy loved
pits Chavez Cantina was the studio 54 of
Tatooine oh you had jub jubs you had
glue Hoss Linda Ronstadt
you had everybody sometimes the Polish
would come in you know I remember
playing their demo he says what the hell
is a Biff and I sat David I don't know
but if I had to guess it was a dude who
can play the [ __ ] out of a fan fire
water now these guys were swinging
through Tatooine and or New York Chicago
LA Minnesota State Fair you name it they
played it hell they sold 50,000 tickets
on Hoth
[Music]
that was a tour bus you wanted to be on
they always had that hash from the
planet chick who once I walked in on him
backstage having a 12 way with some
rubies and it just looked like a plate
of bad clams having a seizure
[Applause]
we've got so much tail seriously
most people we had sex with had tails
and yes okay Siwon doing I got a [ __ ]
from this furry thing with a walrus tusk
we kept in touch for years well no one
ever has been a meal attacked most of
the money we made went up my nose or the
various casinos around the galaxy but
hey you know what we've still blowin
tunes and hey we're all still friends we
are seriously I hate all of you guys
[Music]
[Applause]
you